we've already looked at several ways of
writing linear equations you could write
it in slope-intercept form what would be
the form of Y is equal to M X plus B
where m and B are constants M is the
coefficient on this MX term right over
here and M would represent the slope and
then from B you're able to figure out
the y-intercept the Y you're able to
figure out the y-intercept from this
literally the graph that represents the
XY pairs that that satisfy this equation
it would intersect the y axis at the
point x equals 0 y is equal to b and its
slope would be M we've already seen that
multiple times we've also seen that you
can also express things in point-slope
form so let me make it clear this is
slope-intercept slope-intercept and
these are just different ways of writing
the same equations you can algebraically
manipulate from one to the other
another way is point-slope point
point-slope form and in point-slope form
if you know that some if you know that
there's an equation where the line that
represents the solutions of that
equation has a slope M slope is equal to
M and if you know that x equals x equals
a y equals B satisfies that equation
that in point-slope form you can express
the equation as Y minus B is equal to M
over X or M times X minus a this is
point slope form and we do videos on
that but what I really want to get into
in this video is another form and it's a
form that you might have already seen
and that is standard form standard
standard form and standard form takes
the shape of a X plus B y is equal to C
where a B and C are integers and what I
want to do in this video like we've done
in the ones on point-slope and
slope-intercept is get an appreciation
for what a standard form good at
and what is standard form less good at
so let's give a tangible example here so
let's say I have the linear equation
it's in standard form 9x plus 16y is
equal to 72 and we want it to graph this
so the thing that standard form is
really good for is figuring out not just
the y-intercept y-intercept is pretty
good if you're looking using slope
intercept form but we can figure out the
y-intercept pretty clearly from standard
form and the x-intercept the x-intercept
isn't so easy to figure out from these
other forms right over here so how do we
do that I want to figure out the x and
y-intercepts let's just set up a little
table here X comma Y and so the
x-intercept is going to happen when Y is
equal to 0 and the y intercept is going
to happen when X is equal to 0 so when y
is 0 what is X so when y is 0 16 times 0
is 0 that term disappears and you're
left with 9 X is equal to 72
so if 9 times X is 72 72 divided by 9 is
8 so X would be equal to 8 so once again
that was pretty easy to figure out this
term goes away and you just have to say
9 times X is 72 X would be 8 when y is
equal to 0 X is 8 so the point let's see
Y is 0 X is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 that's this
point that right over here this point
right over here is the x-intercept when
we talk about x-intercept we're
referring to the point where the line
actually intersects the x axis now what
about the y-intercept well we set x
equals 0 this disappears and we're left
with 16 y is equal to 72 and so we could
solve we could solve that so we could
say alright 16 y is equal to 72 and then
divide both sides by 16 we get Y is
equal to 72 over 16 and let's see what
is that equal to that is equal to let's
see they're both divisible by 8 so
that's 9
/ - or we could say it's 4.5 so when X
is zero Y is four point five and so we
could plot that point as well X is zero
Y is one two three four point five and
just with these two points two points
are enough to graph a line we can now
graph it so let's do that
so let me whoops that I was using the
tool that would draw a straight line let
me see if I can so the line will look
something like that
there you have it I've just graphed I've
just graphed this is the line that
represents all the X&Y pairs that
satisfy the equation 9x + 16 y is equal
to 72
now I mentioned standard forms good at
certain things and the good thing that
standard form is maybe somewhat unique
relative to the other forms we looked at
is it's very easy to figure out the x
intercept it was very easy to figure out
the x intercept from standard form and
it wasn't too hard to figure out the
y-intercept either if we looked at slope
intercept form the y intercept just kind
of jumps out at you at point-slope form
neither the X nor the y intercept kind
of jump out at you the place where slope
intercept or point-slope form are
frankly better is that it's pretty easy
to pick out pick out the slope here
while in standard form you would have to
do a little bit of work you could use
these two points you could use the x and
y intercept as two points and figure out
the slope from there so you can
literally say okay if I'm going from
this point to this point my change in X
my change in X to go from eight to zero
is negative eight and to go from zero to
four point five or the little Delta
there unnecessarily let me so when you
go from eight to zero your change in X
is equal to negative eight and to go
from zero to four point five your change
in Y is going to be four point five so
your slope once you've figured this out
you could say okay this is going to be
change in Y four point five over change
in x over negative eight and since I at
least I don't like a decimal up here
let's multiply the numerator the
denominator by 2 you get negative
9 over 16 now once again wait to do a
little bit of work here we either use
these two points it didn't just jump
immediately out of this although you
might see a little bit of a pattern of
what's going on here but you still have
to think about it as a negative is it
positive you have to do a little bit of
algebraic manipulation or what I
typically do if I'm looking for the
slope I actually might put this into
into one of the other forms especially
slope-intercept form but standard form
on it by itself
great for figuring out both the x and
y-intercepts and it's frankly not that
hard to convert it to slope-intercept
form let's do that just to make it clear
so if you start with 9x let me do that
in yellow if we start with 9x plus 16 y
is equal to 72 and we want to put it in
slope-intercept form we can subtract 9x
from both sides you get 16 Y is equal to
negative 9x plus 72 and then divide both
sides by 16 so divide everything by 16
and you'll be left with Y is equal to
negative 9 16 X that's the slope you see
it right there plus plus 72 over 16 we
already figured out that's 9 halves or
4.5 so like it right well I'll just
write that is 4.5 and this form over
here much easier to figure out the slope
and actually the y-intercept jumps out
at you but the x-intercept isn't as
obvious